It was a century ago when famed World War
I German fighter pilot Manfred von Richthofen
was fatally shot out of the sky.
Yet, his nickname – “Red Baron” – remains
part of American vernacular.
Charles Schulz’s comic strip character Snoopy
famously took on the Red Baron in his imaginary
air battles aboard his doghouse, often yelling
“Curse you, Red Baron!”
Movies and songs feature the German war hero.
Even a Minnesota-based food company co-opted
his name and image to sell frozen pizza.
So, who was the Red Baron?
And why do we celebrate him, even though he
was an enemy of the Allied Forces who, beyond
some number of unconfirmed kills, shot down
a confirmed 80 Allied planes during World
War I?
Born on May 2, 1892, Manfred von Albrecht
Freiherr von Richthofen was the son of a career
army officer in a prominent Prussian family.
During the first decade of his life, he lived
comfortably as an aristocrat, playing sports
and hunting.
But at age 11, his father forced him and his
brother to enroll in the Cadet Institute at
Wahlstatt.
Richthofen’s 1917 autobiography reveals
that he wasn’t too happy about this.
“As a little boy of 11 I entered the Cadet
Corps.
I was not particularly eager to become a Cadet,
but my father wished it.
So my wishes were not consulted.”
He goes on,
I found it difficult to bear the strict discipline
and to keep order.
I did not care very much for the instruction
I received.
I never was good at learning things.
I did just enough work to pass.
In my opinion it would have been wrong to
do more than was just sufficient, so I worked
as little as possible.
The consequence was that my teachers did not
think overmuch of me.
On the other hand, I was very fond of sport,
particularly I liked gymnastics, football,
etc.
I could do all possible tricks on the horizontal
bar.
So I received various prizes from the Commandant.
Beyond this, he also was apparently fond of
pulling “risky tricks” like risking life
and limb by climbing the town’s famous steeple.
As you might imagine, Richthofen soon separated
himself as fearless and bold, a reputation
he’d maintain for the rest of his life.
Shortly before his 18th birthday, he was commissioned
as an officer in a German cavalry unit.
On June 28, 1914, a Bosnian-born Slav nationalist
named Gavrilo Princip, protesting the integration
of his country into the Austro-Hungarian Empire,
assassinated the heir to the throne, Archduke
Franz Ferdinand.
Contrary to popular belief, nobody really
cared much about the actual assassination
(not even the Emperor himself who wasn’t
shy about his opinion that it was a good thing
that this particular heir had been killed),
but it was a great excuse to wage a quick
land-grab war, and as a result the world got
one of the most deadly conflicts in history.
As a 22 years old cavalryman, Richthofen was
sent off to both the eastern and western fronts
where he served mostly as a messenger.
It soon became clear that, in this age of
trench warfare and advanced weaponry, cavalrymen
were no longer terribly useful and provided
an easy target for the enemy.
So, Richthofen got off the horse and was mostly
used to find telephone operators and to help
the army with supply transfers.
He was not happy with this and asked to be
moved to the German Air Service.
In his autobiography, he wrote that he sent
a polite letter to the Commanding General
making this request but “evil tongues report
that I told him: ‘My dear Excellency!
I have not gone to war in order to collect
cheese and eggs, but for another purpose.’”
Whatever he actually said, Richthofen’s
request was granted.
After a stint as an observer on flights, Richthofen
was promoted to pilot.
However, his first solo flight didn’t go
well.
In a great life lesson for all of us, this
man whose name would soon become synonymous
with “Flying Ace” crashed.
One fine evening my teacher, Zeumer, told
me: “Now go and fly by yourself.”
I must say I felt like replying “I am afraid”
But this is a word which should never be used
by a man who defends his country.
Therefore, whether I liked it or not, I had
to make the best of it and get into my machine.
Zeumer explained to me once more every movement
in theory.
I scarcely listened to his explanations for
I was firmly convinced that I should forget
half of what he was telling me.
I started the machine.
The aeroplane went at the prescribed speed
and I could not help noticing that I was actually
flying.
After all I did not feel timorous but rather
elated.
I did not care for anything.
I should not have been frightened no matter
what happened.
With contempt of death I made a large curve
to the left…Now came the most difficult
thing, the landing.
I remembered exactly what movements I had
to make.
I acted mechanically and the machine moved
quite differently from what I had expected.
I lost my balance, made some wrong movements,
stood on my head and I succeeded in converting
my aeroplane into a battered school ‘bus.
I was very sad… and had to suffer from other
people’s jokes.
Flying went much better for him after that.
Like when he was younger, Richthofen earned
a reputation for pulling risky maneuvers – like
flying into a thunderstorm against the orders
of his commanders.
His boldness again caught the attention of
his superiors.
In 1916, Germany’s top flying ace at the
time, Oswald Boelcke, handpicked Richthofen
for the new air fighter squadron he was putting
together- Jasta 2.
Richthofen was a cocky pupil but didn’t
disappoint.
In September 1916, he got his first confirmed
kill when he shot down a British plane over
the French countryside.
Wrote Richthofen later about this event, “I
was animated by a single thought: ‘The man
in front of me must come down, whatever happens.’…
I give a short series of shots with my machine
gun.
I had gone so close that I was afraid I might
dash into the Englishman.
Suddenly, I nearly yelled with joy for the
propeller of the enemy machine had stopped
turning.
I had shot his engine to pieces.”
From then on, his confidence and reputation
only grew.
Upon the death of his mentor Boelcke (due
to an accidental mid-air collision with a
fellow German plane), Richthofen took on the
mantle of Germany’s top flying ace.
While racking up kills, Richthofen acquired
some rather morbid traditions.
For example, for every plane he shot down,
he had a Berlin jeweler make him a small silver
cup.
However, after 60 of these, the jeweler was
forced to tell him he could no longer make
them due to a silver shortage.
He also had the habit of following his victims
down when possible and collecting some sort
of souvenir from their totaled plane or lifeless
body.
With regards to one of his early kills, he
states,
My opponent fell, shot through the head, 150
feet behind our line.
His machine gun was dug out of the ground,
and it ornaments the entrance of my dwelling.
In no time at all his home was decorated with
pieces of propellers, compasses, pistols,
and fabric serial numbers torn from uniforms.
He even had a chandelier made from the engine
of a Frenchman he killed- “From the ceiling
of my dugout hangs a lamp which I made from
the engine of an aeroplane…
I fitted small bulbs into the cylinders; and
if I lie awake at night and leave the light
burning, its glow is reflected on the ceiling,
and God knows the effect is grotesque and
weird.”
In January 1917, he was handed command of
his own squadron, Jasta 11.
In celebration, he painted his Albatros D.III
a distinctive, eye-catching red.
He soon learned that this bright coloring
had the desired effect as a sort of calling
card, as he states after an encounter with
a pair of Englishman:
I felt some human pity for my opponent and
had resolved not to cause him to fall down
but merely to compel him to land.
I did so particularly because I had the impression
that my opponent was wounded, for he did not
fire a single shot.
When I had got down to an altitude of about
1,500 feet engine trouble compelled me to
land without making any curves.
The result was very comical.
My enemy with his burning machine landed smoothly,
while I, his victor, came down next to him
in the barbed wire of our trenches and my
machine overturned.
The two Englishmen, who were not a little
surprised at my collapse, greeted me like
sportsmen.
As mentioned before, they had not fired a
shot, and they could not understand why I
had landed so clumsily.
They were the first two Englishmen whom I
had brought down alive.
Consequently, it gave me particular pleasure
to talk to them.
I asked them whether they had previously seen
my machine in the air, and one of them replied,
“Oh, yes.
I know your machine very well.
We call it ‘Le Petit Rouge’ (“The Little
Red”).
April 1917 became known to the Allied forces
as a “Bloody April” largely due to the
Red Baron’s elite squadron achieving an
astounding 89 victories, accounting for a
full one third of the Royal Flying Corps’
losses that month.
It’s also noteworthy that the “Red Baron”
was responsible for 21 of those confirmed
kills in that single month alone.
In the summer of 1917, Richthofen reached
the height of his celebrity as the squadron
leader of an elite unit that all had their
planes brightly painted.
Because of this, the group earned the nickname-
the “Flying Circus.”
He became a powerful symbol for the Germans,
held up as a fitting example of a perfect
soldier.
Unfortunately for him, in July of that year
Richthofen was severely injured when a slug
grazed his head and caused a fractured skull.
He was able to land his plane in friendly
territory, but it was feared that he was close
to death and the injury soon required multiple
surgeries.
Three weeks later, though, he returned to
flying against his doctors’ orders, but
this time in an advanced Fokker Dr.1 triplane,
the aircraft that is most often associated
with the “Red Baron” despite the fact
that he only made the last few of his kills
in this plane.
On April 20, 1918, he got his 80th and final
kill when he shot down a British Sopwith Camel.
At this point, however, like so many other
soldiers on both sides at the time, Richthofen
had lost his taste for the war.
Beyond accounts from friends and family about
his changed demeanor, while staring at the
aforementioned chandelier made of an enemy’s
engine, the Red Baron wrote the following,
When I lie like this I have plenty to think
about…
Now the battle that is taking place on all
fronts has become really serious; nothing
remains of the “fresh, jolly war” as they
used to call our activities at the outset.
Now we must face up to a most desperate situation
so that the enemy will not break into our
land.
Thus I have an uneasy feeling that the public
has been exposed to another Richthofen, not
the real me.
Whenever I read the book I smile at its brashness.
I no longer have that brash feeling.
Not that I am afraid, though death may be
right on my neck and I often think about it.
Higher authority has suggested that I should
quit flying before it catches up with me.
But I should despise myself if, now that I
am famous and heavily decorated, I consented
to live on as a pensioner of my honor, preserving
my precious life for the nation while every
poor fellow in the trenches, who is doing
his duty no less than I am doing mine, has
to stick it out.
I feel terrible after every air battle, probably
an after-effect of my head wound.
When I again set foot on the ground I withdraw
to my quarters and don’t want to see anybody
or hear anything.
I think of the war as it really is, not “with
a hurrah and a roar” as the people at home
imagine it; it is much more serious, bitter.
A hundred years later, there’s still no
firm conclusion on how the “Red Baron”
was actually killed.
In the morning of April 21st, the “Flying
Circus” engaged a group of Allied fighter
planes flying low over northern France.
The altitude in question was significant here
as it was sufficiently close to the ground
for Australian and Canadian machine gunners
below to join in the fray.
From this, it is curious that Richthofen chose
to engage in such a battle in which he’d
be taking fire from not just the planes but
many enemies below; he is known to have advocated
against such generally unnecessary risk to
his subordinates.
Some have speculated from this that he simply
didn’t realize at first he was behind enemy
lines, and thus perhaps didn’t know the
soldiers on the ground would be shooting at
him.
Whatever the case, the decision to engage
cost him his life.
During the battle, Richthofen was hit in the
torso, ultimately causing damage to his lungs
and heart.
As to who fired this shot, to this day the
Royal Air Force (RAF) gives official credit
to Canadian Captain Arthur Roy Brown for killing
the Red Baron.
However, it’s noteworthy that Captain Brown
was flying above and slightly to the left
behind Richthofen when he supposedly fired
the fatal shot, yet the bullet that pierced
his body came in through the right armpit
and exited through the upper left part of
his chest.
It’s speculated from this that the shot
must actually have come from one of the machine
gunners below.
As you might imagine, many people were keen
to take credit for finally bringing down arguably
the greatest flying ace of either side in
WWI, so determining who actually fired the
shot is an effort in futility today given
all the conflicting accounts.
Whoever killed him, the 25 year old Red Baron
did manage to land in a beet field in Somme
Valley where he died moments later.
Richthofen_funeralWhat was perhaps most amazing
was that, while the Red Baron was an enemy,
he was treated as a hero by the Allied forces.
Since he had come down in Allied territory,
it was on the British and Australians to bury
him.
And they did so, with his funeral being attended
by hundreds of soldiers looking to pay their
respects to the man who had killed so many
of their fellow brothers-in-arms.
In the end, Richthofen was buried in northern
France’ with full military honors, which
included a guard of honor and six Royal Flying
Corps as pallbearers.
Soldiers from the various Allied Squadrons
in the area also made wreaths to lay on his
grave, including one which had the words “To
Our Gallant and Worthy Foe” written on it.
It is also noteworthy that after the funeral
the locals did not take kindly to the honors
given to Richthofen, with the French villagers
desecrating the grave and destroying the cross
over it.
In response, one Allied squadron made a new
cross to put on the grave.
In addition, one Captain Roderick Ross stated,
At the same time General Sir John Monash sent
for the mayor of Villers-Bocage, in which
the Australian Corps headquarters happened
to be located, and told him that he was disgusted
with what they had done and that if such a
thing occurred again he would consider removing
his headquarters therefrom.
This had the desired effect.
Beyond honoring a man they considered a worthy
advisory, there was also a propaganda element
to be considered here; it was an opportunity
to show the Germans that their enemies were
chivalrous and not the blood thirsty savages
that so many propaganda campaigns (on both
sides of the conflict) were spreading about
their respective enemies.
Indeed, photographs of the body and funeral
were soon after dropped over German-held positions
to both prove Richthofen was indeed dead and
to show the respect the Allies had shown him.
Ultimately, however, the French would have
the Baron’s body moved and later, in 1925,
Richthofen’s brother would collect the body
and bring it back to Germany.
The Red Baron’s remains currently reside
in a tomb
in Wiesbaden, Germany.